[Music]
my Indian culture I guess I bring
spirituality openness my love of color
and patterns and fun you know for me
India is a lot of fun and that's what I
bring with me wherever I go
Aparna RORO was born in the plains of
India in 1967 she grew up in the capital
Delhi as well as in the countryside
she left her homeland at the age of 20
she studied fashion design in London and
since then she has lived all over the
world she married her German husband in
India the couple have lived in Berlin
since 2013 I've never really had one
home I've lived in ten countries I went
to boarding school when I was nine so
there isn't one place that's home I
guess home is where my family is after
20 years in the fashion business Aparna
rora decided to switch professions and
indulge her passion for cooking she
opened a restaurant called chutney 5 the
name was inspired by British Indian
writer Salman Rushdie he coined the word
chutney fication in his novel Midnight's
Children to describe the Indian
influence on English culture
the concept behind the restaurant is
that it's it's trendy it's modern and
it's not like a typical Indian
restaurant with Buddha's on the walls
just showing people that India is not
all about poverty and about yoga and you
know there's so much more to India
there's there's this in India there's
modernist in India this fashion in India
and I think that's what we want to try
and show people here that when people
come here sometimes they say oh this is
so unusual it's not it's not typical
Indian it's actually it is typical
Indian it's just not the Indian you know
when Aurora moved to Berlin she missed
authentic South Indian cuisine including
doses of n savory pancake that's popular
there
[Music]
black pepper pork dosa is traditionally
served with various chutneys
[Music]
spices also play an important role in
South Indian cuisine
[Music]
one of the most popular is garam masala
a fiery mixture but you can even make
yourself
[Music]
to make the meat really spicy it has to
simmer in the sauce for at least 45
minutes the doses are made from
fermented rice and black lentil batter
and baked using a CREP maker in southern
India they're served with many different
kinds of fillings
it's typical to India because it's a mix
of a lot of spices and it's it's one of
my favorite dishes because it involves a
little bit of work and a lot of
different fresh and dry ingredients
shuttin fi is located in Berlin Spence
Lauer bad district Aparna Arora likes
the fact that her customers are so
diverse just after the fall of the wall
young creative types moved here and
rents were cheap but that's all changed
now the district is mostly favored by
families
[Music]
it's the place that I lived in when I
first moved here and I guess it was my
my first love in Berlin and I just
thought people spend money and going out
and we're in pencil bag they enjoy good
food they know good food the crowd it's
a very mixed crowd we have 50% for
another 50% Germans so it's it was the
right area for a different kind of a
restaurant shuttle if I specializes in
Gus's
a kind of street food typical to
southern India they're usually served
with a variety of chutneys
this place is definitely a very special
and because the food is real authentic
authentic authentic South Indian food
and plus they have their own
improvisations as well so that that
makes it that makes the written the food
really tempting and very special it's
very spicy I got a feel of my home and
she was really sick I say do not expect
that much that much and there aren't
many good South Indian restaurants in
Germany this one came recommended and
I'm glad to be here
here's the thing her South Indian
cuisine has proved such a hit that
Aparna Aurora has now opened a second
restaurant in Berlin a generic get a
black pepper pork but I am mother Sakai
[Music]